EVAN RACHEL WOOD:
It's always really hard for me
to look at photos of myself
from before.
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I've kept this journal
since I was fifteen.
"I made a new friend."
(MIMICS EXPLOSION)
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
I'm here today
to talk about Brian Warner,
also known to the world
as Marilyn Manson.
♪ (UPLIFTING PIANO
MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SARA LYNN MOORE: He studied
how to manipulate people.
He groomed her.
He's a predator.
Everyone was looking
at Marilyn Manson,
and they weren't looking
at Brian Warner.
WOOD: Numerous women
heard my story,
and they knew
exactly who it was.
I realized
that I wasn't the only one
that this had happened to.
You're not alone.
I know. It's crazy.
WOOD: We were outside of
the statute of limitations,
we had run out of time,
and nothing in our evidence
could help us.
SPEAKER:
Statistically, a lot of victims
take seven to ten years
to even recognize that they
were a victim of this abuse.
♪ (MUSIC SWELLS) ♪
WOOD: I became an activist,
fighting for victims
and survivors
of domestic violence
and sexual assault.
Not only did people hear
our stories, but they said,
"Yeah, we hear you, and
something does need to change."
We need those that will expand
the statute of limitations.
It's really important
to survivors like us.
WOOD: We need to make sure
that this doesn't happen
to anybody else.
I realized that
this is the first time
I haven't been doubted
or questioned or shamed.
This was the first time that
someone was really listening.
I was like,
"What is this feeling?"
And it's this feeling
of being believed.